[Music]
hello everyone um en desu kedo
and tonight I'm going to be going over a
game which you should know by heart now
this is the title of the lecture and I'm
not taking it super little early since I
did definitely do not know this game by
heart
and luckily I have it on the screen so I
don't have to but it's just a really
great game and it's one of those which
it's probably one you guys haven't seen
and it just because it's not played by
you know it's not played by a pass world
champion it's not you know some super
famous game that's in tons of books and
all of this so I figured it would be a
game which mostly you haven't seen it's
not all of you but just because it's not
played by those players doesn't mean it
can't be an amazing game this is
probably one of the most amazing games
I've ever seen
and it's just not it's not amazing
necessarily because the level was super
high or anything like this I think white
played really amazing and black could
have probably played better but at the
same time made understandable errors in
my opinion but it was just such a cool
game because of how the whole thing
happens and also there was a cool
feature which is that literally every
single piece of whites was sacrificed
and it's probably the only game I've
seen where that happened every single
piece was sacrificed so that sounds like
in a massive exaggeration but that's
actually what happened in this game so
it's kind of a cool thing and it's one
which is great to do it was played by a
friend of mine Greg Suhr / who's a GM he
lives in Seattle now hasn't played in a
long time but back in the eighties
nineties he played quite a bit and was a
pretty strong GM this was played in 1993
against a Greek GM called Nikolai DS so
this is the game Greg Suhr / again
nikolai tease
Cerberus what so I'm going to pass
through the opening fairly quickly not
because it's not kind of interesting but
I just think that it's fairly standard
and the most interesting part of the
game definitely becomes later so it was
a king's in Ian Greg really likes this
Knight g2 system it's kind of his pet
system it's one of those systems where
if you don't exactly know what to do
against that it can be very tricky to
face and he knows this positions really
well so he's had a lot of success with
this system so black plate 9 bt 793 it's
a if it's similar to any other system it
would be kind of similar to a to the F
early f3 systems and you'll see why that
is so a 6 there should be 3 F screen so
it does look a little bit like the early
up 3 systems the same ish systems
because you get an f3 very early the
night lands on g3 it looks at least
somewhat similar so black plays b5 and
white pushes c5 so against b5 almost
never do you take you usually either
ignore it completely or play c5
occasionally you play a three to keep b4
out but I don't think b4 is such a big
deal in this particular position so c5
is pretty normal black takes it place
Queen to 7 so fairly normal chess so far
castles and this is something which is
also very typical which is that after h4
but white plays Knight h1 I realized
this Knight is kind of laughable you I
normally wouldn't recommend putting it
right here but the point is that a
reroutes immediately to f2 and it's
actually quite good on f2 it controls
the h3 push it's ready to come into the
center so even though this night looks
horriffic real ugly for one move it
comes right back in so again just
explaining a few things happening in the
opening but personally I kind of like
what's position because I think these
two pawns control the knight very well
this Knights ready to come out White has
clear ideas of playing Queen d2 maybe
trying to play on the D file but okay
objectively it's nothing
so black pigment h5 the typical Kings
Indian type move trying to do something
on the dark squares white played Queen
d2 not allowing Knight f4 e 5 Knight of
2 and believe it or not after this next
move basically black just went downhill
downhill downhill to the end of the game
and it's one of those where it looks
like a pretty harmless move so in the
game black played Knight f8 which again
looks like a normal move you're trying
to put the net on e6 controls f4 and d4
can't get much more normal than that
right
I like Knight up for myself put
immediately put in the night there and
you'll see why the knight would come in
handy there in the game not to give you
any subtle hints or anything so 9 f8 was
played and my first question to you is
how can white win the game by force
that's actually a joke because the game
goes on a long long long ways but
basically white has a way to start an
initiative which does not die out until
black reside so how do you start an
initiative in a position which is I
don't know looks moderately closed no
pieces are interacting how can you
possibly start up an initiative here
f4 is the way to I don't know
lose a pawn maybe
yeah I mean the thing is I like that
you're trying to do something it's but
the problem is that it needs to first of
all it not used to just lose the punch
but also you need to have a clear idea
like yes your Bishop gets out but I mean
I don't think you're doing anything too
special and like the knight wants to
come down for anyway right so probably
f4 doesn't isn't in your best interest I
would say yep okay look a d1 is a nice
building but when I say start an
initiative I'm not usually looking for a
building move I'm looking for which type
of move and those of you who are here
for my last lecture should know this 95
is a move which I like you're trying
you're attacking the Queen you're going
to create a nice pawn duo here this move
looks excellent right but okay you're
giving up a whole piece and again it's
not entirely clear what's going to
happen for example say I play Knight f4
you can play d6 I move here there's
nothing it's just not quite there yet
you know what I mean
it's one of those things where you look
at it you go maybe it's dangerous but
not not quite here so you want to store
this Knight d5 idea in your mind because
it's a really powerful potential right
you sacrifice a piece for these two
mobster palms but at the moment you just
don't have enough avenues into the
position you know what I mean so I would
say that you have the great idea but you
need to prepare it a little first aha
and this move is very very strong so b4
is the natural reply which was played in
the game but just to show you how things
can go horribly horribly wrong really
fast let's say black plays Bishop d7
which also looks fairly normal right you
can take shape rook a1 so again I mean
you can't really do too much here so
Bishop comes back and already it's just
sac city Bishop takes b5 is fine but I
like the even more forcing Knight takes
check
so what's going to happen I mean rooks
coming down here with c6 you have two
pawns for the piece so it's not like
you're even that much material after
here rook a7 anyway you're threatening
rook takes Bishop you're threatening c6
the end is near and it happened so fast
right it happened right at the opening
you're thinking knight of fate was
played how can this move possibly be
this bad but when you're behind the
development your opponent's ready to
kind of come at you you have to be very
careful so already you can see the
dangers in this position black played b4
which at least to my mind is the most
challenging book by far so of course he
didn't do this to move the knight back
to a2
I hope what did white play boom but
what's the difference between this and
94 d5 in other position efore is still
kind of the same I think OB for yes I
was about to say yeah figured you meant
before before is now weak and you have
open lines now right your bishops now
more open the Queen side is more open
it's just a lot more annoying for black
to play now there's also a tactical
reason which we'll come to in the game
so white sacrifices the piece gets this
nice pandu and the funny thing about
this is I wouldn't say Greg is exactly I
wouldn't call him an initiative I
wouldn't call him a super aggressive
player I think he's more of a positional
player but when you present any strong
player in a certain position you know
somehow the blood gets pumping in you're
like wait this position shouldn't be
right something should fall apart here
and he saw this move Knight f8 and was
like ah there should be a way to start
an initiative so sometimes it's not even
about like okay if tal playing this game
you'd like of course he sees 95 right
but sometimes it's really you know
there's there's a nice continuation and
regardless of which type of player you
are you come at it but okay we have this
nice pawn duo but you're still down a
piece so the question is what is black
deuce so black played f5 so this move
looks kind of loose but at the same time
it makes sense because white wanted to
play 94 d6 as one idea right and now
this move gives the King an escape route
potentially it controls 94 and the Queen
now kind of can slide around on the on
the second so this move really makes
sense right it's a normal defensive
smooth so game white continues to push
d6 why not so Queen c6 was played in the
game which again to my mind is the most
natural instead of that Queen d7 could
have been played and here White has a
really nice continuation and it's
definitely not obvious when you first
look at it so take a moment
yeah
this should be fine as a cool idea but
after I play pawn takes pawn takes I can
take your rook right I mean you're
giving away another piece so you need
something pretty strong for it I would
say this is a cool-looking idea but
after tix pigs pigs pigs I mean don't
get me wrong you still might have an
initiative I'm taking lots of pawns and
pieces write your down lots of pieces so
even if I have to ditch a bishop and
move my King here I might survive no she
has to be careful I mean I know it's
easy it's easy to sack someone else's
pieces that aren't your own but pretend
for a moment they're your own pieces and
you care about their well-being and you
don't want to give them up without a
good reason
so there should be five I like it it's
aggressive but maybe too much
now you're remembering my comment that
white sacks all their pieces aren't you
don't worry you'll get your chance all
the pieces will be sacrificed in due
order so yep
Queen d5 is a nice-looking move hitting
the rook right threatening c6 but the
problem is I'm not sure what you do
after this seems like you have to move
back you can and then I take your kind
of your pawns are collapsing in front of
you right I mean these positions look so
promising always when you're analyzing
them you're like yeah pawns push I'm
going to crush but so often if you play
one inaccurate move they just fall and
you look like an idiot
I know because I look like an idiot on
minion occasion so you have to be very
precise with how you push your pawns and
win it's now a good moment to play c6 is
now the Queen d5 the most accurate c6 is
a nice move but what happens after Queen
takes pawn free pawn what was your idea
it should be 5 is kind of nice but you
can actually do something much simpler
which is rook here the problem is this
Queen has no squares where does it go
yep so for example if the Queen goes
here I play rook c7 you have to go to b8
which is just kind of disgusting if you
ask me and now your Queen d5 move
starting in queen up seven thirteen
Queen c6 I think that like black blocks
about to collapse right so you see how
just this one move order thing can
really be because it looks weird you're
giving up one of your connected pawns
but once the rook gets into c7 it's just
really really bad so white black
understandably played Queen here but now
we can revisit one of our favorite ideas
especially by a particular person in
this audience yes quite a move right so
you have to take pawn takes but now the
problem is you don't have time to take
this rook because your Queens under
attack already
so black actually does take this pawn
and gives up the rook which is
understandable because again one of the
things when you're defending is you
can't be too greedy when you
defending and anyone who's going on when
warfare games knows this if you take all
your opponent's pieces probably you'll
get brutally checkmated so at some point
you have to learn to give material back
which is what he does the problem is if
you try to hang on to everything white
just shoves the pawns down black throat
and the game is basically over right
away
for example if Queen b5 now d7 check and
then rook takes aid and then takes on g7
and every piece false and then you
probably get checkmated anyway if Queen
b8 b6 and I don't have to tell you that
this is not pretty
three three pawns on the six I don't
know what it's worth but it's probably
more than a queen oh yeah don't don't do
it
don't do it guys and yeah if rook takes
here which is probably the best defense
you're still down a queen and after
Knight d3 which is a nice move heading
for c5 it's going to be pretty bad so
even though you have a rook and two
pieces for the Queen because the black
Kings here because these pieces are
basically just sitting here as
spectators White's still as a crushing
attack so that's why he took on b5 so
white took the rook Queen c6 and then
white played what
look at say one is a very natural but I
have a question for you what happens
after a for DG see this coming
it's important to see piece trapping
moves before they happen
this is one of those things the question
is how do you save your bishop
you can or I should say you may or both
what happens if I take your bedroom
this looks pretty promising but do keep
in mind that you're still down some
pieces right so let's say I play I don't
know a 97 maybe so I'm going to try to
castle perhaps I assume it's still legal
right I have a move my camp now I always
have to check because I always forget
this you're laughing at me but I often
will think wait can I cancel here
no no I don't know maybe this is
promising but I don't think it's super
clear I think you can do better
but 74 I'll pick it I'm not proud
so now you want rookie one
well you got to make a decision come on
either way I'm running I'm running
putting on the tennis shoes and jogging
away keep in mind if I get too far I can
start sacking material back which isn't
what you want right so again you can see
how you have to be very precise with all
this the white found a much more
aggressive and interesting move but the
question is why now black played 97
which is a much better defense but why
did blacks not take this bishop there
are two answers by the way one is the
cool answer and the other is the boring
you know also good answer so if you know
what's good for you you'll find the cool
answer
Carrie nice you found the cool one BAM
because you can take this night but
after I recapture you have a real
problem because you can't take the Queen
because I made everyone sees on and the
problem is what do you do if you don't
take the Queen what's your move let's
say I play I don't know here out of
desperation take the Queen that's boring
yeah take the queen ridiculous now
taking the green I'm sure is fine but
come on now what
that's the way you end a chess game
luckily for us black defended a little
bit better and I say luckily because
then we get to see white sack the rest
of the pieces
oops so black played 97 which is a much
better move so what now
you like this move I can tell you know I
can castle right I think so look we're
about to my moment of truth whether I
realized as possible yes I knew as
possible okay and your bishops still
trapped by the way huh not to laugh at
you and kind of laughing at you because
it's funny but yeah the bishop on d4 is
still trapped so unfortunate
look 67 is possible what's your idea
after I play Buddha I guess I'll take
with Queen alright I'm just taking
everything give it I want it all I want
it now
yes this is this is attacked at an
attacking temptation which I myself fall
into all the time also I just want to
gave away all my pieces to checkmate the
problem is if you give away all the
pieces you need to checkmate you don't
have any check many pieces left you're
just left with you know a sad King and a
knight and a bishop
and you're done so you have to make sure
you don't give away too much I realize
white gave away all the pieces
eventually but you have to make sure you
do it at the right time so you have the
right idea you should be trying
something aggressive because the problem
is if you allow black to castle and I'm
sure this is what black was counting on
in the game you're in big trouble right
you need a way to prevent this yes
now the Queen prevents counselling and
Queenie six check is a pretty nasty
threat right so black took on e3 yeah 9h
up six doesn't really help you because
you check and you play 94 and this is a
really nice move so the idea is let's
say I play a Ponting video what do you
do now
okay but I can defend with Queenie and I
do that so you're pinned and the next
move is Queen here makes almost a matter
but maybe 98 I'll take it first but now
you're done it's checkmate right pin
pins are pins are nasty people so you
can see how it's very hard to defend
against all these threats black's
decided well I got to take something so
Queenie six was played this is maybe the
one move of Gregg's in the whole game
which I disagree with and it wins it
actually does win but I think that after
Knight d3 black can just resigned
because like what do you do
Queenie six comes next I take your
knight c6 might come you can't castle
for legal reasons talk to my lawyer
about it but um yeah I mean it's just
your position is just resign Abel
however I have to be fair to him but the
way he played it's way cooler
so forget about what's objectively the
easiest we're going to go with what's
cool because we're all cool people
so Queenie six check and he played rook
taykitty summon
so again 94 is a very easy win but again
I kind of liked the way he did it so
pawn takes Knight check so what do you
play now
if you play King tix I play Queen 65
check if you go here I give you a check
again can't go to e2 because the night
f4
if you go here I give you check again
give you check again
check check who's going to get mated
White's going to get made it probably
right either way you go you're almost
certainly something bad will happen to
you I need to say it so you have to be
careful and this is why I kind of like
93 because it avoids all the pitfalls
luckily white is in no way obligated to
take that part they see how easy it
would be to play one careless move and
your beautiful masterpiece goes out the
window so the whole game you have to be
so focused and calculating accurately
every move to avoid it now you don't
have to calculate that much after Kings
except to Queen takes e5 I would just be
like oh no I'm not doing this I wouldn't
calculate any further but the key is to
see that Queen 65 is now checked and
that black can get out of it right it
would need an easy blunder to make if
you're not panicking
so black now plays Queen e8 there are
quite a few possibilities here though
for example Queen 86 check was possible
and after King takes eights
F 2 which is forced Queen e2 check easy
to miss this one isn't it very good
taking is the best move check so stay
back to f-16
keep in mind you're down to pieces still
the game is not just over and believe it
or not in this position and I think he
saw this during the game he calculated a
lot there's only one move to win here
and every other move loses so finding
the winning move is super important
let's just say yes huh oh that's cute
okay I give you props for cuteness on
the move the problem is what happens if
I take it and then I go here
well it's material
who would use position do you prefer you
think so and where is it going let's say
I do nothing the rest of the game
where's this fun going then some wishful
thinking there the problem is because
the square is so well-guarded you're
going to have a hard time winning it now
maybe you're not just dead lost but I
would say the black is the one may be
trying to win because my rooks going to
come out eventually I'm going to try to
win this pawn do I think it's
necessarily a win maybe not but this is
not a clear win for white is it so white
actually has a much better move you guys
just want to give away all your pieces I
don't know it's some kind of disease all
right King ting which one BAM I'm taking
that in two seconds and you've sacked
all your pieces so one goal has been
accomplished but I don't think you're
going to win this game not unless your
opponent drops dead at this particular
moment so
I think you're thinking and too much in
terms of aggression here think in terms
of what piece is preventing you from
just winning here I heard something good
yes
the only move that just win because now
that isit Act and if it moves anywhere
then C seven D seven and those funds are
pretty nasty right but okay let's say so
yeah this is winning let's say go here I
want you guys to show me how it's
winning don't just take my word for it I
lie all the time you Jane if King edge
sone C one careless move it can cost you
the whole game because now if you play
d7 I just take and you're just down a
piece I know it's the sad-looking Bishop
but it's still a whole piece so you're
probably gonna lose you can try this and
hope and pray I take your rook but I'm
afraid but obviously I'm going to side
stuff and again when you're down this
and this is the thing you have to be you
can never get complacent in these games
when you're sacrificing all this
material it's fun there's a wild ride
but it's very important you look at how
can my opponent stack material back
because black can sack back a whole
piece and still be completely winning so
you have to make sure these guys queen
and not only do they queen black doesn't
have too many pieces for the Queen so
what did you want to play so you want d7
instead alright so what if I play dr. oz
I have to take a moment here okay so
what if I play Knight takes D son and
son ha
coiled
aha this is a better option because now
if I let you trade rooks when you play
c7 that's a queen for two pieces that's
too much material right so I have to try
to block but now you still point c7 so
you see what I mean it's not that hard
but you have to take that extra moment
to find the accurate move if you don't
find the accurate move and imagine how
easy by the way it would be to miss
Queen a six and then Queen e2 checks not
so not so easy - not so easy to see so
you have to be on the lookout for temple
moves all the time and make sure you're
calculating accurately to the very end
because a masterpiece can turn into a
disaster really fast there's a reason
why there's probably more disasters than
there are masterpieces a masterpiece is
rare blown masterpiece is very common so
net g3 check is another move which is
important to see so you have to take it
otherwise if King takes Queen 65 Queen
takes d7 keep in mind I was threatening
made on f7 so I didn't have time to
recapture so what do you do now well
this move is fairly easy okay so you're
up a queen but look at this those are
pretty powerful pawns wouldn't you say
or no you're not intimidated by these
pawns I don't know everyone is
intimidated by different things
so how do you win here Queen where
okay zero queen d8 although up here
okay
well this would transpose yeah this this
would be the other variation you could
have just done an internet and without a
movement Queen d8 is an extra move
vessel so here you have two choices I
can play Bishop f8 and what now
do not allow rook h1 check please
that is what
this ah I just have one question how are
you going to Queen okay happens to all
of us you add a much simpler one though
sometimes it's easy to look for kind of
cool solutions because we're looking at
sacrifices been doing cool things
sometimes it's just a simple move and
when you're playing a masterpiece I know
you want to there's this tendency to
want to finish in glamour as well
sometimes you just have to take pieces
and have your opponent resign just the
way things go yeah now rook h1 does
nothing right now rook h1 you just
calmly take this pawn and ask blacks to
resign so yeah now now the game is
pretty much over but what happens if
black plays King h7 i block my rook but
I don't know still doing stuff yeah now
you can actually defend probably even
easier I think this wins to them because
now if King takes you play here and you
Queen it should be fairly easy but d7 is
is also a nice way to and again so those
options didn't work but you saw how
goodnight g3 and Queen 86 we're close to
working right you had to be very precise
to get rid of those options so no matter
what's happening in a game again
precision is so important in the game
black played the Queen here so what now
rook da alright are we playing the piece
giveaway variation again what's going on
see six okay you have an immediate
threat so you're hoping I have no
defensive move here's what you're saying
I mean I could play queen out and trying
to check you if number once I start
checking you you're probably done right
so once I play here you better have like
checkmate immediately all right check
check
I offer a draw but only the same time
what did you want
aha very nice yeah I mean a move like
this looks really cool but now you allow
Queen check again and then the circus
starts all over right and in this case
the circus is a bad thing I'm not saying
circuses are always bad but when you're
winning a circus is that so Brooke f7
check giving away the rook I told you
you're sacrificing all the pieces you
guys didn't believe me I know but okay
so you have to take right now what
mm-hmm very nice so if Queen TIFF takes
the Queen which is I mean if you take
the Queen it's actually a similar
version to the game except the rook
doesn't get out so this is actually a
very easy win because you do something
like this right check King somewhere
Bethel most likely I guess here and then
you continue to push the pawn and it's
just that these pieces are so bad they
can't really do much right
the problem with extra pieces is you
need them to actually do something rook
Bishop and Knight is theoretically
better than a queen but if they're
looking like this which I mean I don't
know what to describe the mess cobwebs
may be I don't know but they're not good
so if the pieces can't do anything
you're just ready to Queen the Back to
Black section material is meaningless
the black found a better move which is
king f7 because at least now the rook
gets in the game right so the question
is how does white finish finish things
how can white continue to to do things
Queen we're okay so let's say I move my
King back here
rookie seven was played in the game but
let's say I move back here how are you
going to win so you want to Queen your
pawn a I have Canadian roots alright
I'll play you fly
okay and now
I mean it's legal I mean I don't all
take okay that's sound logic so here
okay
I think your problem 90 xg3 is coming
right yeah I don't know why you played
g3 though it didn't look that's it I
think that once again you kind of got
seduced by I have to do things in the
cool way I mean pretty sure this is a
fairly easy win yes I get to sack the
bishop but I mean the knight and rook
sometimes can hold against the Queen but
they're so disconnected here that I have
serious doubts about this ever happening
but again maybe it was a possible
defense and maybe you could have done
things a little better I mean I'm not
sure if C if C 7 here works my guess
would be that this is maybe allowing too
much but because okay you can't Queen
here obviously because I check and Queen
and that's embarrassing but maybe even
here you can take king moves king king
e2 and be slightly fancier about it but
I don't
again sometimes you just have to win in
the simple way in this case black played
rookie 7 which makes sense right at the
temple move pinning the Queen very nice
I pack all your pieces well this is a
cool resource right and this is a type
of move where often if you miss a move
like this your win is gone now I'm not
saying for sure that's the case here
but in a lot of cases if you don't play
c6 like if you don't find this most
accurate move you end up queening a move
slower and again when you're dealing
like once these pieces like say you take
this prong right now I play you for
again probably you take I play Bishop
here I cover the square my knight comes
in next move all of a sudden the game's
a mess it's not clear at all right so
you have to spot the c6 resource the
minute it comes because it not only
paralyzes the rope but now I mean if
black tries to take you're ready to
clean but typically especially if you're
facing a GM or a strong player they're
not going to let you in so easily
they're going to try to find every
possible resource to prevent you from
winning so black found e4 which is by
far the best move so the question is
what do you do
do you play c7 do you take on e4 you
take on b4 do you resign plenty of
options well
then I have four checked well that's not
good not saying all your moves are wrong
but you got to be careful you got to
spot what to do after e3 if you don't
know what to do after e3 there are some
real issues right
yep okay here yeah okay don't tell me
what I'm gonna do I'm just kidding I
will play three check
pong pong yes they're pointing out I can
take the Queen which is true I just
wanted to be kind of more mean about it
but yeah and now you have to be careful
right so this is very important efore
makes a threat the threat is rook takes
Queen and Bishop e5 so regardless of how
aggressive your feel and how awesome
you're feeling yeah I'm sacrificing all
my pieces I'm about to win make sure you
ask yourself does my opponent of a
threat rook takes Queen followed by
Bishop e5 most certainly qualifies as a
threat so you know that your move has to
address this threat right pawn takes e4
does that address the threat no so so
don't do it it's very important that you
address blacks threat f4 might be
possible but then I play e3 so I think
you were onto something the first time
what else you going to play besides
peseta the question is how do you deal
with this threat
okay and up key
so yeah I know so what white did was I
have known Greg a long time I played
against him I think three times maybe
four times something like this I've seen
him play
I have almost never seen him not in time
trouble around mu forty ever he almost
certainly had two seconds on his clock
and was blitzing his moves out so he
does a very common GM thing which is
they just repeat moves if you are
someone who gets it to type trouble all
the time
first of all don't do it it's exactly
four in Greg's in Greg's case it's cost
him tons of games like it's probably
cost some tournaments it's cost him lots
of thing because he just he he's a
perfectionist and a lot of times he
likes to use up all of time if you don't
have time it hurts you but when you
don't have a lots of time in particular
it's nice to repeat Moops a lot of the
time which is you go back and forth if
you're playing the 30 second increments
what you have an extra minute if you
play those moves instantly
pretty cool huh you have an extra minute
to think and your two moves closer to
time control but you have to be very
careful and what do you think you have
to be careful of yes which brings me to
another funny story I had one game where
I was playing against Greg himself
believe it or not Greg server and I was
suffering his black the whole game it
was terrible it was I had I think it was
an isolated pond I played it badly he
was just messing with me the whole game
it was terrible like I just had an awful
awful position but it was coming up on
move 40 and he didn't have time like
what you always and guess what he
repeated that third time so rather than
torturing me for another two hours an
ending or just winning I think the
position was objectively drawn but he
could he would have played it forever I
mean it would have been horrible he
ended up giving up an easy draw so the
repeating twice is a great strategy but
make sure you don't do it a third time
and keep in mind it's easy to do
sometimes because the rule is not that
you have to do it in a row all you have
to do is reach the exact same position
with the exact same person to move
through
times and it's a draw you could do it
non consecutively and it's important to
understand this rule so I'd say if you
can learn anything from Greg as a player
learn this game and learn not to repeat
three times these are the two great
things that he can teach you no I'm
kidding
but yeah I would say be very careful of
this so King up seven and now he took
increase and at this point it's still
you know it's fairly easy clean up but
it's still you still want to be accurate
so for example if Bishop d4 how would
you play here hmm you're fast move
forward II don't don't bother
it's a nice-looking move because the
bishop doesn't really have a happy home
doesn't it can't really go back so this
would be a very nice move because if it
takes here there's a fork if Bishop here
doesn't for confessors here there's a
fork it would have to move away and then
you can just grab so he defends his pawn
at age six and again this is another
thing don't resign too quickly I know
it's the Queen for two pieces but you
have two pawns here and if your Bishop
can defend these pawns it's not going to
be so easy to win so even here even
though White's done almost all the work
White's act every single piece gotten a
queen the game should be over the game's
not over until you really make sure it's
over until they are either completely
hopeless position until you checkmate so
make sure you don't lose concentration
at any point so Bishop h6 how do you
finish the game he played Queen c5 he
wants to take a pawn right Queen c7 just
gives check I don't really see what it
does was not that it's maybe possible
yeah so again there are a few
possibilities he played back to e8
taking the pawn immediately might be
possible I wonder if there was something
he was afraid of here um yeah I mean
sometimes there are more there's more
than one way to you know to do it right
it's not always there's only one one
winning solution but I'm guessing that
he wanted the King on a certain square
or he wasn't sure in any case he gave a
few checks and took this pump yeah so
it's kind of a clever thing and I guess
if King goes back to have 70 maybe
checks again and then takes I'm not
exactly sure keep in mind when you reach
the end of the game there tend to be
more than one ways that tend to be more
than wait the key is that you make sure
you don't blunder which brings me to
this question after quitting
d6 what moved you up to make sure you
spot
you know and now which fun do you take
right don't walk into the fork and now
here
and now he resents
because he's not obligated to take this
pawn but imagine how easy would it be to
miss a move like e to check to miss a
move like Bishop III check so to the
very end of the game you have to be
extremely cautious and make sure you're
seeing things well so again really a
neat game this is I mean it was played
in 1993 so the while ago but I really
think that this game is just an
excellent game and really could be in
any of the best attacking game books and
not only because it was executed
precisely because there were lots of
different motifs but because I mean
every single piece of fact I again even
in college games I can't remember a game
where he sacked every piece so it's very
definitely a cool game I've actually had
the privilege of seeing Greg lecture
about this game himself live to a camp i
sat in pretending I was a student so I
could watch him present this game I only
hope I was able to do it justice because
it definitely deserves a lot of respect
it's really one of the coolest games
I've ever seen for sure and you guys
should get right on memorizing it
because
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]